[Applaudissements]
nommé en dose de ce magnéto on est tous
d'accord c'est que ce pc le jeu
seule la voix compte je vais le tweeté
j'vais l'astag ramé g pas une photo du
micro je veux dire je suis là j'ai une
idée melhoun c'est là parmi les magic
est toujours le même temps sur le même
flegme à léona que johnny malouf
c'est le seul à vous souvenir depuis six
mois j'ai adoré mois alors que vous êtes
doué je trouve ça bien ça m'arrange pas
d'être avec elle medios exil m je ne
sais pas chimiste y avait une autre
réponse et comment sont arrivés les
urnes au premier prime de risque on
bourre les urnes aussi on va passer à
une nouvelle séquence que vous allez
adorer on va parler des animateurs
réponse ils sont échangiste ils sont
échangiste oui ah oui elle aura donc ses
idées renzan horrible que c'est mes
parents paient d'autres ont dû rigoler
de tout et respecte les parents aux
parents c'est important oui oui madame
que sont les candidats de bienvenue chez
nous des révélations étonnantes a été
fait sur certains candidats de
l'émission bienvenue chez vous et oui
sébacées selon télé star elle a répondu
que du poilu alors à côté nous casser
cette affaire en fait très régulièrement
la production arrive pour pour faire les
visites des lieux ils découvrent dans
les tables de chevet des sextoys et en
fait ils se rendent compte qu au fur et
à mesure du tournage que
certains couples ne soyez changistes et
c'est pour ça qu'il participe à
l'émission à savoir don mello changé
bien que sa jolie oui monsieur oui oui
parce que j'ai changé ma maison avec
quelqu un contrat chez le notaire je
vous promets quand on passe chez le
notaire qu'on échange sa maison avec
quelqu'un on est entre les échangistes
monsieur machin monsieur madame ou du
r'n'b oui j'ai tout appris seul but
[Applaudissements]
choquée j'ai une petite info que des
succès était un saut spécial et avec des
échangistes et voulait même changer nos
en bienvenue en nous pour ça